or
excusez moi vous pourriez appuyé sur le
bouton sanitaire et la wii
je
je me souviens
quarante minutes avoue ne pas plier à
leurs quarante minutes de son petit
déjeuner ce mec banking corp lundis des
ravines et non en fait tu profites
détonique est pour
vous et moi non
j'ai mon modèle est aussi une chance
pour qu'il soit bon c'est naze total
ces pratiques alors je chatte parce que
pour conclure je chatte parce que dans
la pièce d'à côté
natalie portman est en train de faire
dessiner review donc on nous a demandé
de ne pas faire beaucoup de bruit on
pour pas déranger mes camarades
journalistes
l'addition par dans tout ce qu'il faut
savoir comprendre à natalie portman
c'est que n'a-t-elle qui pourra pas de h
c'est le sol de gaza l'at-elle le
nathalie nathalie portman ces crimes à
qui un peu moins fort s'il vous plaît
très très beau à lui j'ai très bon tiens
je m'assois oui bien sûr
ça va être galant pas très heureux de
voir ensemble dans cette émission vous
lancer tout de suite pour lancer le
poids et javelot les caméras bonjour
d'intelligence allait bien ça se voit
pas
non on voit que ça c'est beaucoup et
c'est sur int 1 co en français pour
créer beckham répondants français est
rapide et en anglais si jamais les
questions qui frappe et on sait pas bien
merci beaucoup à tout les deux d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui à l'occasion de la
sortie de votre troisième long métrage
avec atos qui planétarium c'est drôle
parce que je me suis formule est très
très tard que c'est un film qui allait
parler de cinéma
donc je m'en suis pas rendu compte mais
je vois bien que le film maintenant est
un film qui parle de ça je pense que si
je me l'étais dit avant j'aurais peur de
jouer en français nathalie ça a été
compliqué ou au contraire il ya eu un
vrai plaisir de comédienne juste avant
de terminer cette image je voudrais vous
faire une proposition d'affichage juste
avoir une petite réaction va montrer la
fiche
voilà la fiche de planétarium ça c'est
le posteur original voilà et on voulait
juste vous proposer celui là
merci beaucoup au cinéma merci beaucoup
merci thank you dieu merci
ok merci tout le monde si beaucoup c'est
un beau boulot